the united states of america is still
the greatest country in the world
there's a lot of people who have
forgotten that lately sure do we have
weaknesses do we have things that we
need to improve absolutely but the
united states of america still has the
american dream
anyone in the world regardless of where
you are born what language you speak
what religion you ascribe to what your
education level is your wealth status or
who your parents are you can come to
this country and you can pursue life
liberty and happiness
those three tenets were written into the
declaration of independence on july 4th
1776.
they were alive and well then and
they're still alive and well today
ultimately the united states of america
is a shining light on the hill we have a
unique blend of democracy and capitalism
it doesn't mean that we aren't without
our faults and it doesn't mean that we
don't have work to do
but there always needs to be the
reminder that there is yet to be a
better experiment there is yet to be a
country who is able to take all of the
complexities of the world and create a
better governance system or a better
social mobility system the united states
of america continues to lead from the
front and sometimes we need to remember
that although the united states of
america is the greatest country in the
world with that blend of capitalism and
democracy we should always be constantly
improving we should be finding our
weaknesses we should be openly talking
about them and then we should be doing
everything we can to mitigate the risks
that they bring to this country
the united states is a very special
place
most people who are complaining if you
ask them where else would you rather
live they don't have a good answer
the united states of america is the
desired destination of billions of
people around the world
we shouldn't forget especially on days
like today independence day that the
united states of america is the best we
have and if we think that there's
improvements to be had then get to work
start doing your part to help actually
improve the country
because there isn't a better option
anywhere else the united states of
america is still the greatest country in
the world it has been for decades we are
the land of the free and the home of the
brave and sometimes we just need a
little reminder that we've got a pretty
good thing going now let's continue to
make improvements let's continue to
solve some of the problems that we're
facing
but don't let the mainstream media don't
let the divisive politics distract you
the united states of america is strong
and it will continue to be as long as
the individual citizens take personal
responsibility to make their local
economies
and their local societies better over
time